Nigel Hayes the Badgers forward and the
game-winner against Villanova next up
will be Florida and he joins us down
Nigel where are you this morning sir I'm
sitting in my apartment enjoying this
wonderful is consequent
God describe what's in the apartment
that might surprise me um in the
apartment am I surprised you I have my
Kobe signed jersey and shoes I have a
Derek 9 Jersey
I have a Muhammad Ali canvass that um a
friend of mine got on this extremely
clean so that probably is gonna surprise
you tonight relief of a UH a male
college athlete my apartment is pretty
immaculate now were you allowed to
accept the Kobe Jersey and shoes did the
NCAA have anything to say about that he
signed them for me so I think I'm
allowed to have something signed I think
that's okay I mean I guess the rule is
if it's allowed to anyone else I think
other people have had something sonic
buy clothes before so I don't think it
should be an infraction or violation no
good so yeah I'm on the clear okay if
you had to get out and you could only
take one thing out of the apartment what
are you taking
oh the Kobe Jersey I live on the 11th
floors or off the balcony have you ever
worn those have you ever worn the shoes
no of course okay of course not notice
it in that glass box you know until I'm
the old grandpa on a rocking chair that
say hey yeah and then I'll make up a
story you know how scalp
Scalabrine did with his stories about
playing in the championship and what
else say yeah because do you think
Kobe's going to be asking for a jersey a
signed jersey with your shoes um I could
only hope so I mean I got a lot of work
to do before I get to that nobody you
just said to him right now
Nigel you need to you know be up front
you know proactive and send it to him
just just to say hey I just want to say
thank you and the best way possible and
that's to give you my jersey in my shoes
as well well I mean I think he would
look good in a badger jersey definitely
I mean I hope you'd wear it once
he supported us a couple years ago it I
think is you know giving those good luck
helped us get it a lot farther in that
tournament we had a tough road there so
hopefully by him putting the jersey all
he can give me you know that luck I need
to turn that corner all right
speaking of turning the corner though on
the play now take me into the huddle
what is discussed is there a is there a
specific play that coach had in mind
oh yeah he just wanted to get me
isolated onto the right wing and then
try and make a play from there and when
I got the ball we had a little on my
side of the court we got although up
screen action the kind of distract or
you know get a rid of some of the the
baseline traffic strike attack and then
fortunately I made a great play a lot
either Michael Jordan or Steve Smith
whichever one you pick I'm a young sucks
so I don't know which one I should
attribute it to but I've heard both so I
just say I made a good play in the ball
land for us did you know what you were
going to do when you got the ball um no
not at all in my mind oh my gosh I'm
taking the fall out and I think I do a
pretty good job on the living moments
and be surreal so I before I get the
ball Mike Wallace's this is a big moment
right now you know I ride right now I
started to listen to my heartbeat I like
man my heart's beating really fast like
it's kind of like how in the movies you
know everything started going slow I
look back at my mom that's probably what
it was you know her look is what it gave
me what I need to do and um I got the
ball in tried to attack baseline and
then I know I needed to keep long cuz if
I came back I'd be tried so I did the
fake spin popped in and then you know
the rest is history how nervous were you
um probably not as nervous as you were
because I heard you picked the Villanova
talent so well it's a shameless wow what
a little less nervous and you were yeah
for your bracket I will say I didn't I
didn't want you on today because you
hurt me with Villanova but then my dad
said no he it was a big shot you're a
journalist you have to you know rise
above that so yes you're right I pick
Villanova to beat Wisconsin Yeah right
you got me Nigel but to answer your
questions there was uh it
I think those are kind of the moments
that you you live for that you want as a
player to be in a position make a big
shot against a really really great team
and I try and win your team the game so
I think it was probably um for me once I
got the ball inbounded one of the you
know calmest moments of the game do you
have to go to class today no we're on
spring break but I have an online exam
for a class I'm taking intermediate
finance so yeah yeah so everybody's
going to nice formal other places for
spring break and you're you're there in
Madison I'll definitely take that that
means we're so that's four years from me
with no spring break and I couldn't be
that okay wait did you have a back-up
plan in case you guys had lost for
spring of course not there was no there
was no thought of ever losing I mean
that's just the confidence not the not
any arrogance or anything but we just
believe in ourselves we believe other
believe what we can do if we play right
when we play right and we knew that we
had a chance unfortunately for us and
when we acted on that did a great job
and be you know a really really great
team and a team everyone including
yourself you know thought would repent
that is true and no I I had North
Carolina winning at all not not
Villanova did you yeah but I've got you
guys beat in Florida this is not even
gonna be a game I can't concur those
although I do wish we can win we know
that there are obviously a good team
otherwise there would be the sweet 16
they want their game a heck of a lot
easier than we want ours so can we play
what's in the refrigerator we did this
with your former teammate Frank Kaminsky
oh good old Frank I love Frank have you
heard from Frank he's been tweeting
about your guys seating in the
tournament and he was disappointed that
yeah I [ __ ] it on the guys yesterday
they saw us in the attacks out there or
not yes yeah yesterday a few days ago on
FaceTime with sam yesterday checked on
him Frank sent me a text down cuz on my
snapchat I was posting some pictures of
some of my well who I thought were my
friends and they were telling me that
hey I'm sorry I picked against you and
I'm like wow well and then they're like
well I still wanted
to do well but it was you know they were
betting money and I was like wow so you
really play against me we're supposed to
be friends so it kind of hurt so I was
kind of exposing the fake friends whom I
thought were real so now my circles
gotten even smaller I like that okay
what's in the refrigerator let's play
what's in the refrigerator with Nigel
Hayes the Wisconsin Badger forward I
have silk almond milk nice and if you're
familiar with Jay Cole he has a line
that says he never thought they'd be
drinking almond milk and Here I am it's
actually really good um I have some
mushrooms spinach that my parents left
over my parents are vegan so when they
came up last time they brought once it
is storing out all their vegetables I
hate mushrooms I'll have a water bottle
I have what else do they like pickles so
here is elastic um I have some chunky
sauce at Tostitos my mother likes
chipotle mayo so I have that barbecue
sauce is an essential and my Brita
filter that is all that in my
refrigerator it's pretty sparse in there
Nigel well you know my Badgers play a
Florida that'll be coming up on Friday
late Friday night so I'm gonna be up
with the wife and kids and I'm gonna
have my badger gear on routing on whisk
will you yes I will soon as I got less
constant badger huh
that way we could upload a picture so
the world can see this visual as soon as
I get my whisper Johnson badger gear
then then I'll send that out okay well
we're on a national broadcast so I'm
sure a lot of people have heard that so
I would do my best to get you that gear
and I would make sure that you are you
know supporting the right team as you
should be and I will be more than happy
to tweet this out I've shown my support
for my Badgers here well I thank you sir
I appreciate it means a lot extremely
touching it really is Nigel good luck on
your online test today no cheating okay
of course not even though it's open book
I would do my best thank you Thank You
Nigel take care that's Nigel Hayes of my
badgers
at an online test today the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience